Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
I get a lot of messages from you Fellow Scholars
that you would like to get started in machine
learning and are looking for materials. Words
fail to describe how great the feeling is
that the series inspires many of you to start
your career in research.
At this point, we're not only explaining the
work of research scientists but creating new
research scientists.
Machine learning is an amazing field of research
that provides us with incredible tools that
help us solve problems that were previously
impossible to solve.
Neural networks can paint in the style of
famous artists or recognize images and are
capable of so many other things it simply
blows my mind.
However, bear in mind that machine learning
is not an easy field. This field fuses together
the beauty, rigor, and preciseness of mathematics
with the useful applications of engineering.
It is also a fast moving field, on almost
any given day, 10 new scientific papers pop
up in the repositories.
For everything that I mention in this video
there is a link in the description box and
more, so make sure to dive in and check
them out. If you have other materials that
helped you understand some of the more difficult
concepts, please let me know in the comments
section and I'll include them in the text
below.
First, some non-scientific texts to get you
in the mood, I recommend reading "The Road
to Superintelligence" on a fantastic blog
by the name Wait But Why. This is a frighteningly
long article for many, but I guarantee that you won't be able to stop reading it.
Beware.
Nick Bostrom's Superintelligence is also a
fantastic read, after which you'll probably
be convinced that it doesn't make sense to
work on anything else but machine learning.
There is a previous Two Minute Papers episode
on artificial superintelligence if you're
looking for a teaser for this book.
Now let's get a bit more technical with some of the better video series and courses out there!
Welch labs is an amazing YouTube channel
with a very intuitive introduction to the
concept of neural networks.
Andrew Ng is a Chief Scientist at Baidu
Research in deep learning. His wonderful course
is widely regarded as the pinnacle of all
machine learning courses and is therefore
highly recommended.
Nando de Freitas is a professor at the university
of Oxford, and has also worked with DeepMind.
His course that he held at the University
of British Columbia covers many of the more
advanced concepts in machine learning.
Regarding books, I recommend reading my favorite
Holy Tome of machine learning, that goes by
the name of "Pattern Recognition and Machine
Learning" by Christoper Bishop. A sample chapter
is available from the book if you wish to
take a look. It has beautiful typesetting,
lots of intuition and crystal clear presentation.
Definitely worth every penny of the price.
I'd like to note that I am not paid for any
of the book endorsements in the series. When
I recommend a book, I genuinely think that it provides
great value to you Fellow Scholars.
About software libraries. Usually, in most
fields, the main problem is that the
implementation of many state of the art techniques
are severely lacking. Well luckily, in the
machine learning community, we have them in
abundance. I've linked a great talk on what
libraries are available and the strengths
and weaknesses for each of them.
At this point, you'll probably have an idea
of which direction you're most excited about.
Start searching for keywords, make sure to
read the living hell out of the machine learning
reddit to stay up to date, and, the best part is yet to come: starting to explore on your own.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!